>> Tucker: INCREASINGLY
POLITICS IS NOT CONCERN OF
FRINGE LEFT.
POLITICS THAT DOMINATES THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION.
ELIZABETH WARREN APOLOGIZING
TODAY TO CHEROKEE NATION FOR
TAKING D.N.A. TEST.
THAT IS NOT ALLOWED ANYMORE.
MEANWHILE AHEAD OF ISSUING THE
PARTY RESPONSE TO THE "STATE
OF THE UNION" ADDRESS, THE
2018 GEORGIA GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE STACEY ABRAMS
WRITTEN AN ESSAY DEMANDING
MORE IDENTITY POLITICS IN
MILES PER HOUR -- IN AMERICAN
LIFE.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> ELIZABETH WARREN ANNOUNCED
SHE WOULD RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AND PUT AN EXPLORATORY
COMMITTEE OUT AT THE END OF
DECEMBER.
SHE IS STILL IN THE
EXPLORATORY PHASE BUT MAKING
WAY FOR THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
BILLIONAIRE "FREELOADER."
WARREN APPEARED ON CNBC
YESTERDAY THAT SHE WANTS
BILLIONAIRES TO PICK UP THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
>> I WANT THE BILLIONAIRES TO
STOP BEING FREELOADERS.
I WANT THEM TO PICK UP THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
>> ASKING FOR THEM TO DO THEIR
FAIR SHARE IS NOT UNCOMMON BUT
CALLING THEM FREELOADERS IS
UNCOMMON.
SHE MADE HEADLINES FOR
APOLOGIZING TO THE CHEROKEE
NATION FOR THE D.N.A. TEST SHE
TOOK IN THE FALL.
FOR YEARS HER NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTRY CLAIM FOLLOWED HER
AND THE D.N.A. TEST PROVED SHE
HAD NATIVE AMERICAN BLOOD BUT
MANY, MANY GENERATIONS BACK.
THEY GAVE A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT SHE HAS APOLOGIZED TO THE
DESCRIBE AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S ROOTED IN CENTURY OF
CULTURE AND LAW AND NOT
THROUGH THE D.N.A. TEST.
IDENTITY POLITICS, STAS SAY
ABRAMS RAN FOR THE GEORGIA
GOVERNOR WILL DELIVER THE
DEMOCRATIC RESPONSE TO THE
"STATE OF THE UNION" TUESDAY.
SHE WROTE THIS EMBRACING
IDENTITY POLITICS.
SHE WROTE INSTEAD THE
AMERICANS MUST THOUGHTFULLY
PURSUE AND EXPAND IDENTITY
CONSCIOUS POLITICS.
NEW, VIBRANT NOISY VOICES TO
MANAGE IF PAINS AND EMBRACING
THE IDENTITY AND THE PRICKLY
UNCOMFORTABLE CONTOURS.
THE AMERICANS WILL BE MORE
LIKELY TO GROW AS ONE.
BEFORE THE "STATE OF THE
UNION" ON TUESDAY, ABRAMS WILL
BE IN A SUPER BOWL AD ON
SUNDAY PAID FOR MY FAIR,